right now I turn to the phone lines and
find from the NFL media group who was at
the Colin Kaepernick workout at Georgia
and also was the one who first noticed
Kaepernick sitting during the national
anthem during a preseason game over Oh a
few years ago now he is Steve white
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Steve hey rich I'm doing
good a little fatigue it had to swim
through a lot of stuff this weekend down
in Georgia but I was exciting to do
story with Kaepernick stories is not
going to go away I know and again you
were it was your report many moons ago
that first started this whole I guess a
story to use a phrase and the latest
being the workout that went down this
weekend in a high school as opposed to
the Falcons facility and it all boils
down to a lot of legalese that you just
got off the phone with the league about
I give you the floor as to what you know
on this run yeah first off let's start
this off by saying there's just
significant distrust surrounding all of
this and and that's why you know
Kaepernick backed out of the league's of
the league sanctioned workout the
Falcons facility they don't trust you
know what the league you know how they
put this on but at the key you know some
of the argument now you're hearing from
Kaepernick side is the fact that the NFL
tried to make them sign a waiver which
they were not comfortable with so when
speaking to people from both sides
the Kaepernick side said the waiver
there was language in there that could
could prevent them down the line from
suing the league for collusion or
something of the like and now remember
Kaepernick sued the league for collusion
and made a settlement him and Erick
reader with the Carolina Panthers so
when speaking with the league and
they've sent me copies of the waiver
they said there is no language in there
had Colin Kaepernick decided to sign the
waiver there is no language in there
that would prevent him from suing the
league for collusion or anything on
those grounds all of the language is
there is set to protect the league that
should have any player gotten injured
during the workout they could not do the
league they could not sue the Atlanta
Falcons where the facility what the
facility and their employees who are
going to be staging this event they
could not sue the National Scouting
Combine Service who is putting on the
event or any of the coaches including
Hugh Jackson and Joe Philbin who are
going to be working so again the
distrust in the matter of interpretation
looking at the same document and
breaking down terms differently were
part of the Harbinger on this and also
in speaking to caps people rich they
wanted the media and an independent film
crew to come in they notify the league
of this about three hours before the
work I was to be scheduled a part of it
you know both in with let's put it this
way but in $20 when I workout was
supposed to actually take place the
league was not comfortable with an
independent film crew the league was
just telling me hey look the one thing
we want to show is that you coming back
to the NFL to some of these owners who
have had doubts won't create a circus
and if we let in all this media
dependent film crew that could add to
the circus element of it Kaepernick's
people are saying that has nothing to do
with it we want transparency and we
don't want the weakens filming this and
possible film of the workout right
that's to be sent to all 32 teams just
trust it really is what unsettled every
well there's so much to unpack right
there Steve from the fact that if the
league had gotten busted for slicing up
video of Capernaum I mean I'm look bad I
couldn't even imagine the league
attempting to do that because of the
ramifications that would come PR and
legal in their direction that that one
just but then again as you pointed out
this comes from a place of distrust to
begin with that's that's the first thing
what not the first thing but one of the
things another thing too however is that
clearly clearly the language that needed
to be hammered out for both sides to
feel comfortable certainly with the
level of distrust required more time
than just the five days between
announcement and you must accept this
workout and the workout taking place so
I understand why Kaepernick's group
would think there had to be something up
so the question I have is from your
reporting where did this initially come
from from the league that it had to
happen that it came out of nowhere
and it had to happen that Saturday five
days later come you know what our high
water Steve and rich that is the one
unanswered question that we just cannot
get we we have not heard a solid answer
on that I have talked to teams I have
talked to people in the league and that
is the one answer we are not getting we
have seen reports that Jay Z was trying
to push for Kaepernick to get a workout
I do know that there were people and the
high and high ranking spots with the
league office who had no idea about this
until it was announced on Tuesday that
that this workout was going to happen
but I spoke into general managers who
are like we had no idea this was coming
until we got the email saying hey on
this date you know on Saturday there's
gonna be a workout for Colin Kaepernick
but flowery branch the Falcons facility
so these teams are like wait a second
we've got our pro the rest Nigel to do
some advanced scout we've got to arrange
you know now we've got a real if we can
get there of course general manager
right there because her teams play games
on Sunday oh the the whole the hastiness
of this being put together again that
was the first seed of distrust for
Kaepernick's Catholic why now why
couldn't we you know slow play this and
negotiate the terms that was part of it
and then you know some teams were
inconvenient all said all that said and
I witnessed this there were more than I
witnessed personally more than 20 NFL
personnel executives I mean some of them
high rank all the food chain Oh Andrew
Barry Hardy rosemond's right now no
department up they were there they
showed up to see Colin Kaepernick and
the fact
that only eight ended up going to the
workout at the high school kind of tell
you how this either sat with teams or
how this conflicted with schedules of
guys had to catch flights to other games
but the fact that 25 teams did take the
time with all of this going on the
hastiness on the fact that they showed
up telling you that there worked on
football teams interested in seeing him
and from someone I spoke to rich they
said not only did they want to see them
to possibly look at him for their team
they won the only thing that are
developed in the three years he's been
off and his skills that mm-hmm had to
face him so the among football people I
seem to have thawed the Kapernick could
possibly get a shot and maybe he still
will well and on that front before I let
you go Steve I know you've got a show to
do for the NFL Network so the question
is is you could look at it this had
something for everybody to try and use
against the other or bolster a case
widening the distrust okay so because it
can be said that the NFL tried to get
Kaepernick working out at the most
nefarious way to try and get him into
some sort of trap that he could not sue
them successfully for collusion okay not
that preventing him from doing it at all
but to sue them successfully forking for
collusion and then on the other side the
worst case scenario that Kaepernick just
wanted to show up and show that he could
still play knowing that he thinks he
won't get a chance to play and that's
all that mattered to him is to just
throw more mud on the NFL figuring I'm
not getting the job let me just torch it
up show up in a [ __ ] akin to a t-shirt
in a high school working out blowing up
their plans and that's all that mattered
so where is the truth in all of this and
where do you think it moves forward best
as you can tell having been there from
the first moment that he sat during the
national anthem to this day
I tell you rich just speaking in the
short term with this happen this weekend
that would be a whole lot of effort to
prove points on both sides
it really would if if you're trying to
make Colin Kaepernick look bad that's a
whole lot of effort especially if you're
asking 25 teams got just a 25 personnel
men who have jobs to do to pull them out
of those to do that is a whole lot of
effort to make him look bad and for
Colin Kaepernick that's a whole lot of
effort to make the league look bad when
this was all dormant when everybody had
moved on so to speak Colin Kaepernick
was doing his things in the community
and his personal life the league attacks
a great season that is a whole lot of
effort just to stir this pot so it's so
moving forward it's just I'm just
interested in who because rich you and I
know those who cover the sport know this
the NFL people for three years have said
Colin Kaepernick could play Pete Carroll
came out and said when they brought him
in a couple years ago he's a star during
this Lee he can play it is not the NFL
people that have kept Colin Kaepernick
out of the league so now all of a sudden
we're talking about all these GM's and
personnel people in this net who came to
see him and didn't come to see him and
this and that maybe they could they
could have a shot but the owners of this
team don't want to look up their minds
to give him a shot and like I said
thawed but after all of this we'll see I
don't think if he gets a call and all
they're good for this season it'll be in
the off season for Corning Corning
that's what companies are told me but it
just it's it's so wide open this
described that was theirs come on pick
now in the bathroom Moses all over the
place I don't know how owners are gonna
interpret any of this who would want to
do would want to deal with it and who
wouldn't Steve appreciate the time at
watch 89 on Twitter must follow and I
appreciate all your hard work on this
story and absolutely every single all
the one that I get to work with you on
the NFL Network thanks to the call
brother same here rich take right back
edge and that Steve white right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show